hey everyone its Mike from order flows
and this is a special video on trading
the overnight session with order flow
you know one of the questions I get
frequently from people is you know I
don't say they're new to trading but you
know they might be a bit new to order
flow and trading on a shorter timeframe
as opposed to swing trading or trading
you know on a daily chart because you
know order flow is best used intraday
and you know one of the questions that I
get is hey you know I've got a full-time
job and I can't watch the markets you
know during the day what what other
options do I got well you know there's
two options one you can trade basically
the night session trade the u.s.
products at night or obviously you can
trade you know the European or the Asian
markets during that time but what I'm
going to talk about in this presentation
is the u.s. products the products that
trade on the CME and you know there are
decent trading opportunities and I'm
gonna get into that so you know before I
began a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract are making any
type of investment decision futures
trading contains estancia risk and is
not for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk apples money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results know full
disclosure I do sell a software the
order flows trader software which you
can go to overflows calm and find out
more about and you know that's the tool
that I use in my trading and that's the
tool that I use in these video
presentations so what do I mean by the
overnight session well I mean overnight
Chicago time in short basically the
reopen of zme at 5:00 p.m.
Chicago time and until about 6:00 a.m.
she cago time which is 7:00 a.m. New
York time and you know for me that's
that's sort of the when the u.s. session
really begins now this is a info graph
like a cat from the sea and me groups
it's a little bit dated its January 2016
so it's not two years old but honestly I
don't think it's really changed that
much but you know just gives you an idea
of sort of the type of volume that
you're seeing at overnight and this is
based on the Asian day basically 8:00
a.m.
8 p.m. singapore time which depending on
daylight savings is basically you know 7
asre 7 p.m. Chicago time till about 7:00
a.m. Chicago time so basically you know
the the European session and most of the
Asian session so you know euro dollars
this is the short-term interest rate
that's not euro currency futures you
know that's why you know you don't trade
tuna three million contracts in the euro
currency but this is the euro dollar
most people don't really trade this
unless you know it's a it's more of it's
a short-term interest rate and you know
that it's traded mainly by banks and
hedge funds but contracts that most
retail traders trade emini SPS ten-year
notes crude oil vibes gold Aussie
dollars to a certain extent you know
most people don't really trade copper
they you know the one thing I wish I had
on here was the euro currency but I
probably didn't make the list cuz at
that time the volume relative to the day
session isn't as great but I'd be
curious to know what it is and I wish
they would update this and make it
available to people actually a broker
sent me this couple years ago that's why
I have it but you know it's interesting
email yes peace 13% you think God 13%
it's not that much but when a contract
trades you know two million three
million contracts 13% is a lot you know
back in you know 2016 when the average
daily volume was you know 2.4 million
13% is 300,000 you know for certain
contracts I'll say for certain for a lot
of contracts they'd be happy to trade
that amount during the normal day
session crude oil 150 thousand over 160
thousand during that evening session
until 7:00 a.m. New York time you know
that's a lot you know you can see here
gold whole session 193,000 Aussie
dollars you know about 50% of this
volume happens during the evening
session you know that's a lot you know
it's fifty seven thousand contracts on
average copper you know 24 thousand but
you know these are solid numbers so you
know there is activity at night
you know it's not like they're trading
you know 5000 contracts or anything like
that back in the old days now you know
the reason why I wanted to make this
this video and just you know sort of say
educate you guys but yeah I used to work
these shifts before basically since the
1990s from 1995 or 96 so I left the CM e
floor and I went to the upstairs trading
desk until well when I was in Singapore
I you know I've worked Singapore day
hours which is obviously the night
session but you know for you know gosh
not mine
not my entire career but you know for a
very good portion of my trading career
you know definitely you know from the
90s up until 2016 there abouts you know
these are 2013 when I left Morgan you
know 15 years at least working those
hours so I know the type of
opportunities I know the liquidity
that's there and there's great trading
opportunities and you know if you sort
of discount are thinking the volume is
not that good you know you know you're
not gonna be interested in it you know
think again honestly think again know
when you're looking at these markets
okay I just want to you know just one of
the things that's I think you got to
keep in mind is the type of chart that
you're gonna look at and people that
normally know I like to use range based
charts but I also like to look at minute
based charts but minute based charts in
the overnight session sometimes don't
give you good handle on what's really
going on whereas a range based chart you
know it's it's not time dependent the
wait a minute base chart is range based
chart is based on price movements rather
than time movement so it's not like it's
hey it's six o'clock and I got to form a
new bar just because it turns six
o'clock you know range based chart will
form a new bar when you know a new high
or low is made based on you know the
sort of the time by that the the price
range that you're using like in this
case zero currents yeah like 8 range
charts like 8 range charts for like your
currency crude oil ESPYs and not so much
I prefer like a 4 or 5 range chart bonds
fives like four range charts you know
buns for range charts interest rates I
prefer forming charts and same with the
grains for range charts as well but your
currency since the other there's quite a
bit of volatility you know if you look
at our form range chart in the markets
moving very quick you're gonna get you
know trading opportunities but by the
time you get in the markets
you know already made a decent move that
you're gonna lose out on I don't know I
just prefer an eight range chart on your
currency I used to use ten but you know
eight ranges is good enough for me
now the thing with a contract like say
the euro currency is you can get more
volume when the European session opens
and you can see it here on 2 a.m. so
just really quick ok so you can see this
is a train chart and the bars are nice
you know you got very decent but very
solid volumes coming and now even
granted there's gonna be times like here
go back you know from this is 2100
forces Chicago time to 20 to 14 so you
see it took over an hour for you know
this bar to complete here before you
started the new bar you know there are
periods at night where there are you
know what I call periods of you
liquidity and if you're trading
sometimes it's gonna be very slow and I
mean that's just the nature of the
markets nothing going on in Asia maybe
there's a holiday in Asia that there's
just nothing going on then when you get
into the European session you know
things pick up and it starts moving at a
decent intervals you see your bars
forming and you know 2 or 3 minutes
basically so it's it's not too fast it's
not too slow but during the Asian
session it can be quite slow given a
choice and would you rather trade during
the Asian session or European session if
I was going to trade the Asian session
honestly there I would trade an Asian
based contract I would trade Nick I has
very good movement I would trade Hank
saying palm oil I mean nobody's
interested in that except me that's just
because I have a yes contract that I
traded for a very long time and I sort
of know it very well but you know that
the main contracts nikai topics you know
JG B's not really
but Aussie dollars you can trade as well
there's a decent movement there your can
see you can trade but like I said you
know you're gonna come into these
periods where there's just not much
going on you know and it's gonna take an
hour to form especially you got a
position on alright and the last thing
you want to do is be on a position get
in a position and the market not going
anywhere you know that that's what
drives the upper walls as a traitor is
that the boringness of it and it can get
quite boring during the Asian session
there are times that you have good
movements like you see here I'll granted
this was Sunday night
you know we're reopens they tend to get
good movements because it's the first
time the markets trading since Friday's
close but for things like euro currency
I think it's it's a good contract you
know 1:00 a.m. you know when the
European session starts you know people
start coming in to look at the European
session but you know just get really
quick here you know this is a great sign
opportunity you know people that you
know if you kept my software you know
you have access to my courses you have
access to my inner circle and you know I
talk about this type of setup right here
it's giving a nice little move down
there you know what else you got here
you know you start going up up up no no
you get some decent movements you know
from 122 123 38 you know down to 22 so
there's there's opportunities this is
another great selling opportunity right
there do the glue things just sort of
going sideways sideways sideways and
again you know it's it's you get this
nice little move down there there was a
terrific trade there's a nice trade
opportunity here as well get short I
thought that was a terrific opportunity
you know getting short from the 123 you
know Oh 304 area you know it puts in a
nice 20 cent move down there 20 to 24
takes you know it's 40 haptics which is
your currency trades in you sort of come
down into these swing lows I was looking
at this morning you know when he cut
down into this area I was looking for a
reason to buy I kind of half-hearted
like this this one not so much
I was interested in here as kind of
disappointed that just went sideways
here but you know what you had the
bullish ratio right after the swing low
and you had the stacked imbalance coming
in here you know to me this was like an
all systems go
type of trade but then it came right
back with the bearish ratio here the
imbalances you know the trap traders
signal right there and unfortunately
just went sideways you know I thought
this was it we can probably trade back
up above 123 we didn't but you know what
there was signs right in here right in
the next bar that it wasn't going to
work out you just sort of went sideways
sideways sideways into where we are
right now now okay so this is a range
based chart you know compare it to a
minute based chart and you know just
really quick here it takes a little take
some time here with ninja trader to
update you know if you're using a minute
based chart
you know you get bars like this which is
you know the kind of doji Xena opening
closing that same price where it's just
a one price level you know and it's you
can't really make solid trading
decisions off you know extended periods
like this you know four or five bars you
know this was a nice there are some nice
bars in here but you know it's it's not
being consistent right yeah I just
prefer my bars to give me you know use
the information that the markets making
available to you you know there's a lot
of information out there and and with
trading sometimes it's it's how you take
that information and put it into an easy
to read format or a format that you can
get some value out of you know this is
the swing high you know on a minute base
chart is you know it did give me a
decent selling opportunity you know it
did say hey yeah you could probably take
a low-risk sell here but then you just
sort of run into these bars that like
this you know or this is it's it's it
just sort of screws up you're you're
thinking you're like you know I gonna go
sideways or not you know obviously
things start picking up again you start
getting the bearish ratios coming in but
you know that's just the trade-off that
you take if you're training a minute
based chart during that time period you
know if you were to go back to it here
so like two o'clock right this is the
European session basically the open
and you know that's why you get you know
it's such a big bar you know it's it's
always gonna be a struggle sometimes if
you're trading markets that put in bars
like this over extended periods and then
boom you get a big bar like that
although granted this is because of the
European open but you know if you go
back here you know it's like there's
just nothing going on and that's why you
get these little bars like this you know
it's just basically you know one price
level basically the bid and offer
trading one price level you know it's
honestly it's hard to make heads or
tails out of anything like that you know
here you got this this extended period
of time
or they're just saying nothing going on
you know are you gonna make any sort of
trading decision based on volume when
there's basically you got one contract
traded in this period another one
contract two contracts three contracts
six you can't you can't you know that's
why I prefer to use a you know a range
based chart you know and as opposed to a
minute based chart just because you know
that the amount of information you're
gonna get is is much better and much
cleaner all right but the I mean like I
said you know this is the type of bar
that I talk about a lot you know in the
inner circle that you know this is a
great selling opportunity you know
you've got ratio you got point of
control you know everything that you
want in that type of bar to get short on
so you know that there are opportunities
there you know let's just take another
take a look at another market really
quick
crude oil again you know crude oil but I
just showed you the volumes you know it
trades decent amounts of volume that you
can get involved in at night now you
know for me personally I you know crude
oil it does trade a lot during the asian
session obviously trades decent amount
during the European session but for me
where I really think the volume really
picks up is you know basically the 4:00
4:00 a.m. Chicago time which is the old
ice opening now granted you know Brent
trades overnight as well but back in the
old days when Brent used to open up
about 4:00 a.m. she cago time that's
when the volume used to really pick up
but you know again this is an eighth
range chart on crude the same type of
chart that I'm using on the euro
currency and you can see you know that
you get some decent price
once here you know they get this period
of going sideways during the European
open we sell-off here you know not much
really and as far as trading
opportunities this morning and in the
crude in the crude oil but you know I
just wanted to show it to you so you can
see now granted you know you know the
five o'clock reopen five o'clock Chicago
time reopen you know you get some bars
it's kind of illiquid give us some time
to settle down you know granted you know
it was Sunday night so it's the first
time the markets reopened since since
Friday but again let's take a look now
at some of these other markets like a
minis I mean these is you know this
contract that you can trade as well you
know very good volume you know again a
lot of contracts I think would be very
happy to have that sort of volume now
and why would I use a four range as
opposed to an eight range I'll say I do
keep an 8 range open and if the market
is kind of I'll say kind of the market
has more volatility on that day I'll
stick with an 8 range but generally I
prefer a 4 range because nowhere am I
here because it's not moving so much you
know but again you know if we're gonna
if I if I see volatility is high trading
a foreign range chart in my time you get
into a trade the markets already moved
you know a point full point not a tick
I'm talking about points that it's you
know you're missing your opportunities
and the last thing I want to be doing is
training a chart that I can't you know
get the decent entries in the or if I
said hey I gotta buy here and I buy in
and we're training three four ticks
higher you know it's kind of pointless
that I'm gonna be missing all my trades
but let's just go back to the asian
session here so this is 8 p.m. this is
for range chart so you know going back
since going back here what is that five
o'clock reopen you can see there's
there's decent volumes going through
already you know give some time to
settle down european i sorry the asian
session you know things start picking up
here you know you got a bearish ratio
here sells off to a bullish ratio there
it goes back up i this is a trap trader
signal but again you know we're already
moving up you know i prefer these trap
trader signals at swing
close or swing highs rather than at in
middle of moves so if you see something
like that on the software I would prefer
to see it you know at a lower area not
after you know we just sort of been
taking higher like that and we sort of
come up here what time is this this is
midnight yeah I hope this video is
useful as some people but again I'm just
sort of going through here this type of
bar I like you know I got a bullish
ratio you know part of control at the
bottom but it comes right back with a
bearish ratio you know you got the
imbalances in there so you know even if
you're getting along there you know when
you see a bar like this it's seeing
you're gonna get stopped out yeah you
just got to sort of take that loss now
another thing that you know again you
know I have what I call these ratios
right that's what these blue numbers are
there's black numbers there's blue
numbers and if it's a blue number above
the bar it'll be a blue number above a
red candle or a blue number below a
green candle for a ratio that I like if
it's a black number like this 4 point 6
to point eighty four point nine if it
the number is black I'm not interested
in it's just the normal order flow that
you would see going through but when you
start seeing you know blue numbers
there's two types there's a racial
balance hi there's a racial balance
alone so if it's above 28 again you know
on the settings if it's above if it's
above 28 then that's indicating me price
rejection if it's below 0.7 you know
some people use point one but here it's
racial balance high ratio bonds low so
if it's above twenty-eight actually
thirty is the number I like but you know
again I use twenty-eight because you
know if the number comes in at you know
say what like twenty say comes in below
thirty but above twenty-eight you know I
still want to I still want to see it
then you know below 0.6 so in racial
bonds high indicates price rejection
ratio bonds low indicates price support
or resistance so when you start seeing
them appear
yeah I'm bearish I'm bearish when I see
them below I start to think you know
bullish I mean I don't have a bias
generally but that's what I'm thinking
you know I'm looking for a market to
start coming off if I start seeing blue
blue numbers above red candles you know
consistently then I'm looking for the
market to sell off now here you got a
stack sellin imbalance no again you know
I sort of touched on this yesterday you
know take things in context of the
market yeah you got a stack sellin
imbalance but what the market is doing
it's doing nothing it's going nowhere
it's going sideways and you know that
that's not a great training opportunity
right if you're taking stacked
imbalances or imbalances you know in
general you'll be looking for breakouts
rather than in the middle of an area
because it could just be a big order
coming through you know if you're
trading sideways you know and there's
someone with a big order they're happy
that the markets trading sideways
because they know that they could just
they could move there or remove their
size order through the market without
really moving the market because the
markets consolidating for whatever
reason that you know people are just
happy to trade in that area so sometimes
you know big order will just come in and
just power through the market and you
can get a stack and balance in the mark
and just go back to normal afterwards
you know that's that's how people with
big orders think you know they want to
move their order without moving the
market and you know the other thing is
you know generally if I see you know a
bearish ratio followed by a bullish
ratio it's you know it's not a trade
that I'm looking to take like if this
was just a bullish ratio like this right
here this point 11 and there was no
ratio here it was just a regular black
number I'd be more interested in it but
when I start seeing opposite you know
bearish ratio followed by a bullish
ratio to me that's just a sort of a
market that's not really gonna get much
of the move that I want you know here
was a bearish ratio followed by a
bullish ratio then followed by a bearish
ratio did it sell off yeah it sold off a
little bit but for the most part it's
just sort of going sideways you know if
I were to take this long I would have to
get out based off this you know then
this one payoff yeah a little bit it
went down and we're not the greatest
move I just prefer to see more bearish
signs to get short and other signs to be
getting long and I just prefer to see
them sort of lined up together like here
you have bullish bullish
bullish but it's mixed in with you know
a down candle a down candle I prefer to
see it's coming in you know without
these red candles and just sort of start
working our way up not sort of spread
out like that then we make this move
higher and then sort of takes us to
where we are right now so that's a range
no that's a four range chart if you were
to look at a minute based chart compare
you and just compare the minute based
chart to the range based chart on the
e-mini z' give it a sec here for ninja
trader to work you know it's like here
so you're gonna get these periods where
again you know if you're using order
flow you're trying to analyze what's
going on in the market and you know if
you're just trading one price you know
you can get any information off that
where am I here you know I can get much
just can't make any decent decisions off
this period
you can't nothing doe judo judo judo
judo G you know I mean if you want you
trade - oh geez just straight doji's is
supposed to trying to read the order
flow like this normally I would like
this but no this market is it's not
really trading very much you know on a
minute-by-minute at this time you know
volumes okay 138 239 315 you know some
markets you know during the day session
that's that's decent but again it's it's
just not really giving you very much
preceding it you know you're talking you
know some of these bars now you've been
trading 100 contracts you know if you
were to go back to you know even prior
to the European how European session you
look at the volumes it's it's 60 80 40
you know here look at this this is still
you can't make you know this is
completely information that's it's
useless
you know it's information but you know
what I'd rather that's why I prefer
range based charts especially during the
night
supposed to minute based charts you know
if you've ever traded at this time of
night you know around the from 10:00
p.m. she cago time till about 1:00 a.m.
you know you this is what drives you up
the frickin wall yeah okay say hey I'm
gonna get short here okay you get short
and it's it's it's ten twenty ten twenty
two okay yeah you're short at somebody
you know call it something nine and a
quarter because you can't get your halfs
off so you get short at a quarter and
say he's down this 79 okay yeah hey I'm
it's going in my favor but you're short
you know this it's the time is 22
12:22 a.m. and you're just sitting here
got 10 minutes later you know you know
we are one tick into the trade you know
it's just goin sideways like this is
what George drives you up the frickin
wall you waiting for a move and you
don't it's just taken forever for it to
happen eventually it does happen you can
see it moves all the way down here this
it's a seven and a quarter but it's
excruciating it's very excruciating you
know to sit through and I don't have
that tolerance for it but you know can
you you know in short can you trade the
evening session yeah you can you know
what let's take a look at one of my buns
you know buns is a it's a great contract
I mean Dax is a nice contract but blends
is you know it's the German 10-year note
basically and it trades very good while
you know this is a minute base chart but
you know range based charts sale again I
have interest rates I like for range
charts and you get some very good
information you know like here all right
you got this this area right here you so
you got this swing low here you know you
can sort of come up come up a little bit
training sideways you get this nice
imbalance you know it shirts it's in an
area that you've been trading but again
if you're looking for a breakout look
for some signs of the market getting
ready to break out and obviously you got
a stacked imbalance here if you can take
out you know this previous high here
that you've been hitting you say you
know you got some aggressive buying
coming in you know wait for it to take
out that high you take out that high you
get a nice little move up there but they
know there's some this is a beautiful
setup right here this bar
got the bearish ratio up on a control
right at the top you know it's it's you
know it's one of these you know even the
Delta is is nice setting up nicely but
you know this was a great short
opportunity right here
you know from 157 80 all the way down to
70 in the buns and here to 30 again so
this is sometimes you do get moves and
if you're any training arranged based
charts you sometimes think that you know
you get some time in between but
obviously this number I came out here
230 I don't know what number was cause
this move you know this quick three bar
sell off before it rebounded up but now
here 150 in the morning you know cash
cash in the buns is 2:00 a.m. I mean the
future is open at 1:00 a.m. but this is
another great opportunity right here
based on the order flow boom
and you know it's bearish it's the
bearish ratio that you like and it sold
off quite nicely as well so you know
it's you know the buns is a great
contract buns is a great contract at
trade margin is like a thousand euros or
something that 1 euro is ten euro one
tick is 10 euros so you know if you can
grab you know 10 ticks out of it it's
100 euros right there so you know there
are there are nice opportunities to be
had in in the European markets as well
but I won't get into it this video
starting to run a bit long so you know
thanks for watching this you go to my
website order flows if you want to learn
more about order flows and again you
know it's one of those things is you
know don't feel that the only time you
can trade is during the us day session
you know there are opportunities
throughout I'll say it throughout the
night time but throughout the day you
know the training day is it's basically
23 hours more or less that in and there
are other markets around the world that
are good to trade that give plenty of
opportunity I didn't show that the SIMEX
nikai maybe tomorrow I'll do one on or
tonight how do you want on the nikai but
there are some very nice trading
opportunities to be had and markets
around the world you know not just the
US markets but you know there are some
markets in the US euro currency crude
oil
and E minis in bonds to a certain extent
that you could trade during the night
session with decent liquidity so thanks
everyone and have a great day bye-bye